Shane toma de la nevera un gran cubo de mantequilla
cuyo lado mide 5.
Luego corta un pequeño cubo cuyo lado mide
2 de una de las esquinas del cubo.
Escribe una expresión numérica que describa
el volumen de mantequilla que quedó.
Recuerda que el volumen de un cubo está calculado
a través de sus lados, en este caso tenemos 5,
lo que implica que para que nosotros calculemos
el volumen de este primer cubo tendríamos
5 por 5 por 5 ó 5 al cubo.
Vamos a reescribirlo como 5 al cubo.
Si nosotros tenemos este gran cubo que mide
5 de lado y le cortamos un pequeño cubo que
mide 2 de lado, lo que haremos es restarle porque estamos buscando la mantequilla que quedó.
Restaremos el volumen de este segundo cubo,
que habíamos quedado que el volumen de un cubo se calcula como lado por lado por lado.
En este caso estoy utilizando el 2, dado que
es la medida que tiene cada lado de este cubo chico,
sin embargo también podemos reescribirlo
como 2 al cubo.
Y de esta manera, tendríamos una expresión numérica
que nos describa el volumen de
mantequilla que nos quedó.
Vamos a comprobar nuestra respuesta...
¡Y es correcta!